it's time for the week 17
awards whether it's offensive player
week defensive rookie coach etc mds
joins us we say good afternoon to mds
and as always we started off with him on
the first topic
offensive player of the week for the
final week of the regular season
well for week 17 i wanted to recognize a
few players we haven't talked about much
and so i started with isaiah mckenzie of
the bills who i don't think we've
mentioned at all this year and he had
two receiving touchdown and he kind of
exemplifies to me
what i think makes this bill's team so
dangerous is they just have so many
different ways they can beat you i i
don't know if there is a team in the
league maybe most people would say the
chiefs but i just think about when when
i'm thinking about how would you go
about stopping this team
the bills the way their offense is
playing right now i don't know if
there's a team in the league i would say
gives you more headaches if you're
trying to figure out how you're going to
stop them than these bills
mds you know exactly how to stop the
tennessee titans and yet very few people
can do it and that's to stop derek henry
and that's why he is my player of the
week they needed that win to win the
division it took all 60 minutes for them
to do that 4138 a last play field goal
to beat the texans and they needed every
one of derrick henry's yards 250 yards
two touchdowns 34 carries we saw what he
did late last season and into the
playoffs and here he goes again over
2000 yards just a terrific season fifth
most uh in nfl history i'm sure he will
get offensive player of the year three
200 yard games just outstanding player
all year long but specifically in this
game and as they go forward that's who
all these teams whoever they play we
know the ravens are up first and they
couldn't do it last postseason can they
stop derek henry this postseason mike
yeah and it got so bad on
sunday for the houston texans
defensively giving up those yards that
eric dickerson actually was nervous
that
that the game was going to go to
overtime
and that derrick henry was going to get
to 2106 with the extra time in the game
and i could have seen that happening he
needed 79 yards it would have been a
thing of beauty they got the ball in
their 20 and and off he goes for 80
yards to break the record in overtime
and eric dickerson because mike taurico
said the other night on one of the
digital tapings that we do after
halftime of the sunday night game that
dickerson was texting with jim gray and
jim gray was texting with mike torrico
that dickerson was getting nervous
during the game about that very
eventuality all right my offensive
player of the week is antonio brown we
got to give him some love he finally had
a huge impact on a game because mike
evans got injured and it shows that in
the event that mike evans can't play
this weekend against washington
they'll be fine or close to fine with
antonio brown he had 138 receiving yards
on 11 catches and two touchdowns he hit
one of his 250 000
incentives he had three of them in all
based on catches one on yards one on
touchdowns but but he had a major impact
that's why tom brady wanted him there
and this this buccaneers team
is peaking at the right time yeah they'd
love to be playing at home they would
have loved to have won the division they
would have loved to have had the bye
week but they're happy with where they
are they got that five seed going
against a team with a losing record
pencil them in for the division around
and i think they could really make some
noise especially if antonio brown plays
like he did on sunday next up defensive
player of the week for week 17 mds who
do you have
i have troy hill of the rams who had
that big pick six at the end of the
first half you know the cardinals were
winning at that point in the game and
they were in field goal range right
before halftime troy hill grabs the
interception runs it 84 yards for a
touchdown that was at least a 10 point
swing and you know troy hill also had a
pick six in the week 13 win over the
cardinals so he played very well in two
very big games for the rams down the
stretch uh he's not the first guy we
mentioned not the second or third guy we
mentioned when we're talking about the
rams but i think he's an important part
of what they do and one of the reasons i
think the rams defense is going to be
pretty tough to score on in the
postseason
mds the giants obviously thought they
were playing for something when they
were playing the cowboys and as it turns
out as we all know they weren't playing
for anything but they still played a
heck of a game and i'll tell you who had
the best game for the giants and that's
leonard williams just an unbelievable
effort seven tackles three sacks five
quarterback hits three tackles for loss
and a pass breakup and he had the two
biggest plays in the game the cowboys
had first and goal and could have gone
ahead in this game late in the game and
williams sacked
andy dalton for a 10-yard loss and then
two plays later he actually got pressure
on dalton that forced the interception
that won the game for the giants just
outstanding and i think he's proving
that the jets were right when they spent
that high draft pick number six overall
in 2015 on leonard williams but he's
proving it for the giants and i think
he's made himself a big payday coming up
this offseason mike
my uh defensive player of the week
darius leonard the linebacker for the
indianapolis colts you know he's the
heart and soul of that defense after he
had the strip sack of mike glennon uh
and and the colts recovered and and
he he was pumped he's he's got the
leadership he's got the drive he's got
the talent he's got everything that
defense needs and and this this game
coming up in buffalo could be his career
shining moment it's going to take a lot
to be competitive with the bills but
when you when you combine jonathan
taylor's running ability at 235 yards
on on uh sunday against the jaguars and
that defense when it's firing on all
cylinders who knows what the colts could
do and you know it was the bills beating
the dolphins that gave the colts their
ticket to the season the colts can show
their gratitude by going to buffalo on
saturday and ending prematurely the
bills playoff party i doubt that that's
going to happen but i'll tell you what
the culture when the colts are are
hitting
as i said on all cylinders they're as
dangerous as anyone in the afc
potentially okay rookie of the week time
mds who do you have
i have jerry judy of the broncos and
i've been a little down on him this year
i felt like if you compare his
production to that of some of the
receivers drafted after him he comes up
a little short but i have to say
i was watching that game i don't think
many people were against the raiders he
had a 92 yard touchdown that was
actually the longest reception in the
nfl all season finished with 140 yards
and really showed the promise that he
has and i'm going to be interested to
see
this year in denver with john elway
stepping away
what will the new gm do how how will the
new gm build this team how how much
independence will the new gm have to go
in a different direction than john elway
all of those are interesting questions
to me but one thing i think is very
clear is they do have a good young wide
receiver in place in jerry judy
mds the colts were running all over the
jaguars and suddenly they forgot about
jonathan taylor and then they came back
to him and he showed what they had been
missing in the middle of that game it
might have been a bigger blowout than
what it turned out to be if they relied
on jonathan taylor in the middle part of
that game but he still finished with 253
yards it set a franchise record edran
james had the old record of 219 in the
year 2000 and he's just been outstanding
jonathan taylor has over the last six
games he's averaged 123.5 yards and
scored five touchdowns and they're gonna
lean on him hard this week in buffalo
mike
i knew when i said 235 it didn't sound
right it was 253 he had more than derek
henry he had i didn't realize tied for
the second most by any rookie in league
history at 2 53 tied with demarco murray
impressive performance at a time when a
guy's supposed to be hitting the rookie
wall i remember one of the concerns
about jonathan taylor all the carries he
had at wisconsin too much wear and tear
and he's on its hair right now and
that's going to be one of the
ingredients for the indianapolis colts
if they want to have a chance against
buffalo on saturday my rookie of the
week jk dobbins who was the key piece of
that machine that generated
404
rushing yards for the ravens 404.
think about what we we've discussed so
far this segment derek henry with 250
jonathan taylor 253 the ravens were 404
and dobbins had 160 of those what the
hell is this league become i thought it
was a passing league
not this sunday and sims said earlier
this week that this is just part of the
cycle that with the defenses being
spread out and trying to spread out and
cover the receivers that teams are
seeing openings running the football
guys don't tackle like they used to and
there's an opportunity to gash teams in
the running game and uh the ravens
gashed the hell out of the bengals on
sunday all right coach of the week time
mds who do you have
i have bruce arians who i think has
really got the buccaneers peaking at the
right time i'll also give a little
credit to the buccaneers offensive
coordinator byron leftwich
since thereby in week 13 they had the
latest bye week in the league
they went 4-0 after the buy they're
averaging 37 points a game they're
averaging 448 yards a game since the buy
they really have their offense playing
very well at the right time and i really
like the coaching match-up we get in the
playoffs bruce aryans and his offense
ron rivera and his defense i think
that's a better game maybe than people
are giving credit for obviously
washington has a losing record and made
the playoffs anyway
i think that might be a more
entertaining game than we think
kevin stefanski won't be with the browns
this week but he was with them last week
and his 11 victories
were the most in team history for a
first coach since paul brown which was
ages and ages and ages ago but he got
him to the playoffs and
they they now have an opportunity to go
to pittsburgh and see if they can knock
them off without all these coveted
losses that they're gonna have and
without stefanski on the sidelines but
he has done a terrific coaching job this
year mike and shown that he was the
right choice for the cleveland browns
finally
yeah i think he is ultimately going to
win the ap coach of the year award
because he made the playoffs brian
flores didn't if brian flores had and
stefanski hadn't i think it would have
been flores but one guy who may steal
away some votes who knows sean mcdermott
coach of the bills he's my coach of the
week for one very simple reason the
dolphins went into buffalo
playing for their playoff lives the
bills already had either the two-seater
the three seed and as it played out they
would have the two seed even if they'd
lost and they still pounded the crap out
of the miami dolphins 56 points it was
like mcdermott didn't want to take his
foot off the gas he he got freaked out i
think by the cole beasley injury week 16
but at the same time when you're in that
zone when it's clicking when it's
working you don't want to stop and and
that team right now is the most
dangerous team in the nfl we'll see if
they can continue it on saturday but
right now they're the best team in the
nfl and mcdermott deserves credit for
keeping them
at that level and scoring 56 points
against the dolphins team that had led
the league in scoring defense coming
into that game now not
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports